just a couple of days before super bowl
56 in silphi stadium this man was on a
sideline last time there was a game in
that uh that stadium he is the
quarterback of the san francisco 49ers
courtesy of sleep number trey lance how
you doing trey
i'm doing great how you doing i'm doing
fine last time we spoke was before you
were about to be drafted
that was the last time that was the last
time we spoke
things have changed
[Music]
i should say things have definitely
changed how have they changed from your
point of view trey um
seeing seen the the world the nfl a
little bit differently i would say as
overall you know learned a lot this year
obviously on and off the field
but don't feel like i'm in a really good
spot right now okay what did you learn
about the nfl
i learned i learned the business side of
it a little bit and kind of just how
things work um not not only just within
our organization but just talking to
guys that are rookies throughout the
league learning about you know what
other situations are like
um and you know obviously from a
football standpoint i feel like i'm in a
very very different spot than i was
coming in okay and what is the let's
drill down a little deeper the uh what
business side of the nfl did you learn
about
um
contracts um understanding how people
get jobs and how people keep jobs and
and understanding now that the turnover
i guess my biggest question
throughout the end of the year is you
know
not wanting to ask but nate sud thud was
the guy that that i would kind of come
to all these questions with but you know
how much turnover is it
from a coaching staff like what's
typical um you know getting down to
india because you see it you know on
social media with mike getting the miami
job things like that you know you want
guys to get those opportunities but
you know it's not like college where you
know everyone's there for four years and
then guys are going back so
and and being a rookie at least me
personally i don't necessarily know all
the guys who are in their contract here
you know so so
i was really just wondering uh my
biggest questions towards the end of the
year we're just wondering and trying to
figure out you know what's it going to
look like next year you know what's the
coaching staff are we going to have half
the guys leave
especially with with guys on our teams
we had a real cool awesome and
close-knit group of guys on in that
locker room this year yeah and that
that's you know i heard that from pretty
much every 49er that i spoke to and
again i have not spoken to you
since the day bef i think two days
before you were in fact drafted by the
49ers so um
how much uh
were you expecting to start this year at
all
for the 40 um
my mindset going in was was just to to
be able to compete after you know being
there getting drafted you know the
whirlwind
um ricky minicamp you know there's
really no way to to have a whole offense
learned in the most 10 days that you get
between the draft and reiki mini camp so
for me leaving otas i think was kind of
an eye-opener for me a little bit i
wanted to to be able to compete you know
because if you don't know it well enough
you can't compete so came into training
camp and felt like you know i at least
put me in a position
mentally or i was ready to compete um so
i didn't really put expectations on on
starting any games honestly i was coming
in trying to learn as much as i possibly
could and be as ready as i possibly can
which i felt like i was every week and
then you threw the first touchdown past
the year for the san francisco 49ers
did dude transfer field
yes you did i mean and then the season
unfolded and um you began to
uh appear less in games i mean that's
just one way to put it where it the plan
appeared to be that you would you would
come in or and and not and um and
not spell jimmy g but you know come in
and take some snaps certainly in the red
zone but then that that stopped what to
what do you owe that
trey what can i hear about i think the
biggest thing is you know game prep
throughout the week um
i had a lot of conversations obviously
with kyle about it in game prep
throughout the week you know teams are
going to gain plan
yes game plan for both of us to a
certain extent but but when i was in the
game for the most part you we didn't
know what was going to happen you know
we didn't know if it was going to be in
front of our front uh quarters you know
what i mean it could be a whole
different situation so it got hard
for kyle to to know you know if i don't
get into a rhythm or if i don't play
multiple downs in a row it's hard to
just call the play blindly you know it's
like calling a trick play almost you
know what i mean
yeah sure and then the times that you
got to start the challenges were what
for you
um i actually did those were i think the
weeks i got better um the most not that
i didn't get better every week but you
know obviously taking reps and and every
single rep you get um you know i get
better from so for me those two weeks
were huge i thought in my development i
was super thankful for those because i
think both of them again
i learned so much from from not only
just the game but but the practices and
walkthroughs and everything um just
being in that role throughout that week
was huge for me trey lance here on the
rich eisen show courtesy of sleep number
which we'll talk about in a moment so uh
what whatever you're willing to share uh
with the message you were given in your
exit interviews are you expecting to be
the the starting quarterback of the san
francisco 49ers this fall trailer yeah
it's absolutely absolutely my goal i'm
going to be as ready as i possibly can
you know ta's training camp and
absolutely week one so did they tell you
there will be a competition at this
position uh no no we never no they
didn't say that okay um but obviously
everyone's heard you know if jimmy's
gonna leave if he if he does or doesn't
um
if he does obviously he deserves to go
into a great situation so i think
they're going to make sure that they do
get that done if jimmy does leave right
and so if he does leave then
the gig's yours
pretty much that's the point that's the
plan that's my plan what will it look
like do you think
what will the firefox look like just
meet you as a starting quarterback what
do you what do you envision it looking
like i i got a lot of guys around me
that can make a lot of plays i mean
from top to bottom receiver room running
back room
wide back devo room
i mean we got some weapons special guys
so for me it's gonna be you know finding
ways to get those guys the ball uh as
efficiently as i can and have you spoken
with anthony lynn already have you been
coaching i haven't actually i haven't
actually okay all right
and uh how much in the playbook are you
like on a day like say today i mean what
do you what do you what do you do right
now right now i mean yeah this week i'm
taking some time uh trying to get away
uh but but definitely we'll hit the
ground running again i'm just going
through scripts going through tape
um talking with kyle as much as i
possibly can this offseason i think will
be one of the biggest things for me what
does that come what are those
conversations like i mean we always hear
about coach quarterback
relationships and and
and also coach quarterback
uh connections i mean for the super bowl
coming up this week you we we hear all
about
how sean mcvay and
matthew stafford have progressed
together and obviously joe burrow and
just year two what he's what he's able
to do what what about that with you and
kyle shanahan
yeah i think it's just uh for for me and
for us it's just continued to build that
relationship i understand how i see the
game him understanding how i see the
game and vice versa obviously i'm trying
to get to that point where
uh it's every time he talks football i i
need to write everything down he says i
want to record it he's just that type of
brain the same with mike mcdaniel he's
one of those people that
i mean i haven't been around too many
people like that where every time they
talk about something it's like it really
means a lot you know and it's one of
those things i want to write it down
because if i don't i feel like i'm
missing out on something
but for me i think yes watching tape
with kyle i think is a big thing whether
it's tape from my games um say from from
jimmy's game to any of the games this
year um understanding how he sees the
game and making sure that we're on the
same page throughout throughout the year
and also you know what's going on with
burro this year
you could see how somebody can go from
top five pick obviously he was one you
wound up being third overall
to go from
[Music]
that
and this year you had a couple of starts
burrow at only about a month of starts
before he got hurt
to the super bowl do you think you can
do that with the 49ers next year that's
the goal absolutely the goal and the
plan and the expectation absolutely uh
but you know a lot of work needs to be
done before then i understand that
um but yeah definitely very excited for
for this opportunity with this group of
guys we have again a real special group
all right tell me what you're doing with
sleep number trey what are you doing so
i've been thankful to be able to be
partnered with sleep numbers it's
perfect for me sleep's always been
important to me since my mom instilled
the 8 o'clock p.m bedtime in me uh but
very thankful to be able to part with
them uh everything they've done for me
and my family i was able to get my
grandparents to bed uh for christmas and
little things like that and they're also
you know a company with a purpose they
donated five thousand dollars uh to
start an annual scholarship uh back at
my high school to the pride of the tiger
foundation so now there will be an
annual scholarship for my name um and
obviously the product the sleep number
360 smart bit uh it's second to none i
don't remember the last time i slept in
it and didn't sleep through the night i
mean it'll adjust throughout the night
for you to keep you comfortable i mean
you can have a heating pad cooling pad
it does a lot and obviously something
i'm very thankful for
all right i'm gonna bite on what you
started with uh what do you mean eight
o'clock bedtime what's that what do you
mean oh
i had eight o'clock bedtime growing up
probably until i was like a sophomore
junior in high school come on
come on
swear
okay i'm going to play this thing though
i have a 13 year old
and i have a 10 year old and i have an
eight-year-old okay
and none of them want to go to sleep
before 8 o'clock none of them and
they're always like i'm getting older
back off dad the 13 year old's like my
my friends are up all night you know i
feel like a baby when you do that
so
trey i'm gonna play this for them and
say look at trey lance look what trey
lance is and who he is good person
that's first and foremost and second
like
look what he's become right is that what
i'm gonna is that yeah let me let me get
in touch with him
actually you know if you want to get him
to sleep number bed that might you know
okay expedite the process no i i
understand that you know i know what my
sleep number setting is i know i've got
a 60. that's me so um
did sure i i mean do you do
babysitting when you're not
getting the bleep we'll talk we'll talk
after this this is an offline
conversation yeah we're good we'll be
able to figure something about 8 p.m how
did you stand like you didn't push back
your mom didn't get pushback from trey
lance and sophomores just so
you know you got so used to it but it
was
and it was a good thing and i'm i'm the
type of person i know i need my sleep
otherwise i'm not someone that you guys
are going to want to be around you know
we wouldn't want you wouldn't want to
talk to me okay i've got it all right
that's that's incredible okay and now
look at you what you have become uh were
you watching the super bowl were you
watching it i'll be at home in in the
bay area okay
little party a little something little
get-together
no no no no party no
no no we we're supposed to be there so
what do you what do you want what do you
eat what's your favorite super bowl food
you know when you're growing up you have
you know the whole big super bowl party
with the nachos and everything like that
nachos is just what i think of when i
think of super bowl party i'm not sure
why but but that's that's fair right i'm
more of a pizza guy
his first ballot hall of fame super bowl
food
yeah i mean yeah it's p it's a classic
can't go wrong okay well this is what
we'll talk about maybe uh one year from
today
when you don't forget about the ones who
are interviewing you you now and the
days before
you get drafted tray right just don't
doubt don't forget when i'm babysitting
that's
[Music]
i won't i won't tell them okay
i won't tell them it's trey lance coming
to babysit them and i also will leave it
up to you to institute that 8 p.m rule
it's just
it'll be a holy heck of a mess if dad
tries i'll be honest
we'll figure it out trey lance everybody
from the san francisco 49ers and
courtesy of sleep number right here on
the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here